this is Matt a Spinelli associate editor  at GameSpot and I'm here to show you  footage of for honor season two's new  hero the shinobi this agile class can  flush your opponent's with its quick  slicing attacks as well as pulling  opponents from afar it can also perform  a variety of acrobatic maneuvers in and  out of battle the shinobi is incredibly  fun to play as but be wary an incredibly  low health pool and somewhat lacking  defensive options counteract its amazing  range and maneuverability how do you  think your favorite class will combat  the shinobi let us know in the comments  below and be sure to check out our  footage of four honors other new hero  the Centurion and while you're here give  us a thumbs up and subscribe to our  YouTube channel  you've lost so Lucy  new captions own seat  victory  thank you